okay I just asked this young man to
borrow some money
one for him like if you give a [__] 20
you will never see him again to like
when you die they'll come your funeral
is this your artist this is your artist
yeah what's your name little man
you rapping
some
where's the back end there
you ain't got enough I'll tell you now
you might get two words out of them look
what you like to pull out I have Mexican
pesos for you that's that new money
okay so you take that no no
can you grab something for me
you ain't gonna see him again and I'll
be feeling in my coins
they be feeling about my heart and I
ain't killer I don't think about my mama
how [__] up in the skrilla help me out
bro yeah you gave him enough you gave
him enough
for the place so you got him enough for
the pesos
when you go to Tulum you got some bread
now right but that's two times this year
my guy yeah
good to see you bro I appreciate you man
hey man it's been a minute I see you uh
you got a lot more new jewelry since the
last time I saw you yes
yes I put everything on today
listen I I I gotta tell you you got I
think you got this uh relationship thing
figured out all right because I see you
got the multiples you got the Lou
Williams going on you know what I'm
saying I feel like every time I see you
got you know there's like a couple of
girlfriends is this one yeah see now but
see now I'm back in two so you got two
yeah and they both know about each other
they both together right now okay and
the way you said it like I got two like
that's not enough you know like I had
three one of them I had them what'd you
do she had to go meaty what happened
what's she doing you had to get her out
of here
was that the one who posted you sleeping
on Instagram nah that was cool
they be catching me plugging and [__]
but I'm cool with it cause like I'm you
know I'd like to be down to earth like
of course I like for people to know that
I ain't no you know what I'm saying up
it is
who don't accept my flaws who run from
you know what I'm saying they're lame to
me that's fake for real listen let me
say something man I think you uh have
got one of the best projects I think
when you played you played me your stuff
I don't know it was a couple months
before it came out you're in the studio
that one night you got one of my
favorite projects of the last 12 months
bro oh yeah you was now that night I
played a lot of the unreleased music
yeah yeah so you know what's gonna
happen nah man you uh yeah I just think
that you're bringing that energy I told
you this when we we're talking that
energy that's been missing from this rap
[__] so like this the West Coast like
this with the West Coast needs that West
Coast players we need that West Coast
player [__] I'm gonna be the one but I
need y'all help of course y'all got to
listen man we trying to rape rape the
West Coast Market let's do it
the market not the women no Demarcus
let's rape the market okay so you sign
this little kid is he signed to you yeah
okay so how do you find how old are you
bro
team you're 10. how do you find a 10
year old
well
they do like popping so he was already
popping at nine eight Tick Tock all for
real yeah where's your parents
[Music]
okay fair enough I'm just saying I mean
it's like kind of like big brother right
here right have you learned any nice
like life lessons from hanging out with
finesse two times
like what
again if we don't eat we're gonna throw
a shot at each other
finesse what's I mean obviously the
hours the album's been out it's been
going crazy uh I've seen you just get
every bag possible under the sun right I
know you got a lot more unreleased music
right when's the next body work coming
you got a name for the new project
uh I don't really want to announce it
that's it right I wanna I probably
announce it probably like another
okay two to three weeks because it's
Unique it's Unique it's me and it's um
it's um
is is life you're gonna you're gonna be
able to feel it you're gonna be able to
feel it I know what I'm saying right uh
how are we feeling about Marcus Smart
coming to Memphis on the Grizzlies now
are you I don't know if you're a big
basketball I'm not a big basketball fan
like that but I heard of Marcus Smart
and I know he cold he's cold I know he
cold so I I I I I I I I believe they
gonna go hard in Memphis cool
y'all be back y'all be back yeah I'll be
back if you're at 25 games something
light yeah you know what I'm saying oh
yeah okay so he'd be all right yeah any
tour uh tour stuff coming yeah
you know money bag yo big booty yeah
sexy red that is number third yes that's
is I would love to hear you do a Pound
Town male remix because I feel like
you conquering that this dude he gonna
have the rawest [__] ever
see I ain't gonna lie I'ma say this [__]
I know you are all right
I might do it you just gotta hop on that
beat just do it for YouTube do it for
the culture we need to hear from you on
pound town bro I might do that for you I
would love that bro I might do this I
feel like you speak for the fellas in a
way that not a lot of people are
what you mean I just mean like I
appreciate right your stance live I want
a lot of yeah because a lot of yeah
like get me money why am I giving you
money nah for real that's that's how I
feel like where's my money at oh oh this
like I got a better suggestion
don't ask me for no money we can make
some money together
yeah we can build we get we could put it
together and get some extras but you
ain't gonna just be getting nothing out
of me okay last thing I want to say uh I
noticed that the new chain this the clan
now I see there's three yeah Ku Klux
klansmen that are hung oh that's hard is
this your label yes okay it's the Brand
This is the brand but we it's like you
know what I'm saying it's like we the
clan you know what I don't think you
could sign a white rapper though yes I
could I just had I just had a I just had
a white wrap a white guy to ask me for a
train imagine signing a white rapper to
the clan I go viral hey you gotta rep it
you got somebody who won
make sure you go check that out visual
um we're looking forward to hearing
music from you little man
yes sir